Are you tired of hearing about Logan Paul? (yep)
That's great. Me too!
(see what you did, logan? you made the man scream)
But before we move on to the next drama that will inevitably happen and forget about everything that went down
There is a few more things that
We need to consider
BUT Pewds YoU SaiD BaD WORd, so YOU aRE NOT alLOwed tO CRiTICize hIM
Shit. I forgot, damn it.
Damn it.
God damn it- keep forgetting. I said the badword. Oh well
*slight chuckle*
You gotta give the Paul brothers some props, you know. They... They got a good ball game going on, you know.
One person does something and all of a sudden you-you've completely forgotten what-how bad the other one was
And then just back and forth.
Uhhh..As you can tell Logan Paul is in deep pain after this incident. He's..-
He's suffering immensely.
Clearly his audience put-..uh..-put their feet down and said: "No, Logan. You..-
You stepped over the line."
A lot of people are pointing out,
with the suicide forest video that "It was just a mistake, okay?
Everyone makes mistake-you make mistake too, Felix." That is true.
I have. I'm guilty. Ahh, but people also started watching Logan's older videos and noticed a continuous pattern.
[Logan]: "So as you guys know I am a little sick, my voice is kinda gone"
"but God blessed tomato!"
[Sound of douche throwing tomato at a wall]
[F]: Did he just throw a tomato...
on a wall?
That's hilarious
[Logan]: "...Deliver you guys the most entertaining"
"Exhilarating incredible content EVER!"
[F]: Please throw another tomato on the wall, cause that was hilarious.
*extreme coughing sounds*
[Logan] "I think in honor of being sick, we're now gonna be selling [Logan and friend laugh] official Logan Paul masks at "
get your own sick mask, and prevent the Bubonic Plague from spreading in your town."
[Waiter]: "This one is uh, just for display."
*pointing at centerpiece*
[Logan]: "Oh so I can't eat them? Ok, that's my bad."
[F]: "...god."
How old is he?
So while in Japan, Logan Paul clearly knew about the Japanese culture. They really value respect above anything.
[Logan]: "I just got to be careful to not like disrespect their culture
cause Logang, Japan is all about the respect." [Logan's Friend]: 'Actually it's true.'
[Logan]: I know it's true, so...
I gotta take my  levels and bring them down"
*LP screams like an idiot*
[F]: "I didn't edit that, to make them look bad. HE he edited that."
*laughing*
I didn't even have to do anything.
Oh man
[Logan]: "This is where you throw coins into the well. You make a wish and they come true"
[Logan's Friend]: "What are you gonna wish for?"
"I wish for.....
...health...  uhh...
... happiness...
and hella bitches"
[F]: "You know when you're in a church, or mosque, or Buddhist temple
there's generally the approach that you..
Keep it down a notch. You're a bit more quiet, like I'm not religious or anything like that, but even then I-I'd still--
You know you need to show a certain amount of respect and you're at a Buddhist temple
Just throwing in money in the thing like whatever
It's so dumb.
[Logan]: "What'd he do?"
Some of the authorities weren't happy about them acting this way and
Their guide is the one that apologizes. He's the one that has to step up and be like, "I'm sorry for this person"
*police and guide talk*
[Logan]: " saving the day with his flashlight.
[Logan]: "What did you do?"
[Friend]: "I was just cleaning myself with water!"
and then he's like 'out, out'"
[Guide]: I'm sorry. Filming's. Filming's"
[Logan]: "Oh, it's the film- oh, it's the vlog"
[Logan]: "Alright guys, we're gonna see you back in a--"
[F]: "because you're at a Buddhist temple. It might be a tourist attraction
and a lot of people there as someone who really loves Japan and loved visiting there
I'm always really on guard whenever I'm there
I don't want to be that person, that Logan Paul, and his friends are I don't want to be
It's not attractive
It's not someone you want to be
[Logan, unironically]: "you know how it is in Japan there all about the respect."
"So we're gonna be respectful for a little bit. I know it's new but we got to do it sometimes"
[F]: "Literally the next cut
*extreme coughing sounds*
"He's not sick"
[F]: "I get that he's sick, and then that's a problem, but then wear the fucking mask dude.
In Japan, it's a big deal to be spreading germs, like, they have the masks not-not to protect themselves from other people being sick
They have them if you're sick, to not admit it to other people. It's another respectful thing, that if you are sick
You don't spread that disease around
It's considered really rude to be sneezing and coughing out in public as well, and it's simple things that you could have looked up
You've been to Japan twice you should know this and if you think I'm just nitpicking at this point. Don't worry. It gets worse.
*Logan bragging about his sub count*
*lol only 15 million*
[F]: "Oh my god Logan, can you be more unfunny and annoying?
God damn it this is just
Uhahahah
UhAhAhAh
Uggggghhhh
[Logan]: "he has no idea.
Hello.
[Driver]: "Oh"
Hi.
How you feel?"
[F]: "Logan's- slogan his whole identity with his brand is, "be a Maverick." That's his merch
That's what he sells, that- that's what he acts like, but you're just being annoying- you're just being fucking annoying.
This is sort of attitude that he's emitting towards his fans like, "be like me be an asshole be an idiot"
This is okay. You know you've gotta be edgy.
You gotta do stuff that no one else does.
But it's like- I get that- I get that not everyone should be the same but goddamnit
I hope no one else is like you.
[Logan]: "If you want to see the fish at the fish market in Japan don't party with 'thots' the night before"
"I'm also not giving up hope."
"See now that's what I'm talking about!"
*logan yells at fish*
[F]: "So Logan Paul goes to the fish market
Which is very famous and...
it's already sorta shutting down because they don't want tourists in there because they're being too... it's being too much of them...
it's becoming too much of a tourist attraction. It's really just people working there.
It's a fish market after all, and then you have Logan Paul of course
furthering that even more by just buying fish
To walk around in public with
Like you have people literally scoffing at him, but can you imagine how many of those there that is edited out?
And of course what a maverick
What a legend
I can't believe he just did that
that is
'le epic'
Wow. I wish I was that brave to do that cuz men that's pretty edgy
[Logan]: "I just want to say one thing though Japanese people are so nice" Logan!
Let me just explain this because I don't think you get it
They're- they're polite, but that doesn't mean they like you okay, they may not tell you "Hey fuck off. You're an asshole"
But they definitely think it
And if you think I'm nitpicking, don't worry it gets worse.
[Logan]: "This was my life"
"the Game Boy Color"
[F]: "so Logan goes
to the market to buy a Game Boy
*logan yells*
"Why?"
indeed why. why? what was the joke?
[Logan]: "Excuse me Sir,
"The game seems to be malfunctioning"
"Mucho broken-o"
*felix repeats*
'mucho broken-o'
mucho broken-o!!
Can we- Neil deGrasse Tyson cringe meme? Oh God.
[Logan]: "Here we go" ..
"Heck yeah, bro"
[F]: "Logan Paul clearly cares a lot about his fans when they ask for a signature
as a good good old meme. He signatures as
as a good old meme, he signs as "chu"
[Logan]: "Don't mind me. Cause I'm American
Pant's comin' down"
"Toyota, I choose you!"
You gotta respect the culture. You can tell how much he enjoyed this meme.
Just look at his face
Hilarious you got me. I am the Pikachu. That's what he's saying right there with this with this expression
These are just the scoffs that we see okay
Just I'm just like imagining the ones that get cuts out imagine that the ones that are like 'oh, that
Maybe that was a bit far'
ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
This is literally just his last three videos before what happened what happened
Watching them it all kind of makes sense, why he reacted with such little empathy
as he did. He doesn't really look at these people as
People he's treating them like something else.
I get it people are tired of Logan Paul by now
I'm- I've clearly made mistakes, too. I'm not allowed to criticize it. I agree 100% with that sentiment
I've always said like I've argued with friends about Logan Paul and people always bring up like "oh, no, Logan Paul
He he's like that older, more mature brother. Logan Is not that bad compared to Jake"
From one sociopath to another okay. I'm a youtuber. I know how they think. I don't watch Logan's videos
I've seen briefly of it, and it's enough for me to know his character and who he is.
He's the kind of guy that plugs his merch when his friend's dog died
[Logan]: "I'm with you, the whole Logangs with you. We got your back. Yeah, it's gonna feel weird
It's gonna feel weird for the next few days. Unfortunately, it is just a fact of life and another fact of life is
literally right now you can get your merch on loganpaul.com/shop, link in the description"
(hahahahah so funny)
[F]: "he's the kind of guy that, fakes his own murder... in front of in front of little kids as le "epic meme"
(and nothing of value was lost)
*children screaming*
[F]: "He is the kind of dude that invites his fan to be in a song with him to boost his ego
and of course plug the merch
He's the kind of guy that makes out with his brother's ex-girlfriend
GoOd mEmE
The kind of guy that tells people to meet him outside of VidCon when clearly told not to do that
That's a danger for everyone someone could seriously get hurt don't do that
*does it anyway*
There's no joke I don't like Logan Paul. I don't like his type of person
He's the kind of person where I feel like- if I even tried to have a normal conversation with it just wouldn't work.
He would always just be like:
*makes noises in Swedish*
"IM A MAVERICK, EHHH"
It seemed like I got in a lot more shit for a lot less
And like I said, I don't think he should have any sort of repercussion or whatever from YouTube
But at the same time #bringbackscarePewDiePie
Season 2. That's right! If nothing is gonna happen
At least bring back scare PewDiePie season 2 we shot the whole damn thing, alright. It's there. It's waiting
ʰᵃʰ
hah
HAH
Remember when plugging your merch used to be something kind of frowned upon like
Okay, alright, you can tell you can do it when you launch it
Maybe you can tell like, but don't shove it into people's faces. Okay?
I Don't know. Squad Fam out
"but god blessed tomato!"
HAHAHAHAHAHAHHAHAHAHAHAHHAAHHAHAHAHH